This episode of Real Engineering is brought
to you by Brilliant, a problem solving website
that teaches you to think like an engineer.
The US military has the strongest and most
diverse navy in the world.
The US militaries fleet of aircraft carriers
is so large, it makes the US navy the second
largest airforce in the world, second only
to the actual US Air Force.
A single Nimitz- class aircraft carrier like
the USS Ronald Reagan, a 6.2 billion dollar
nuclear powered ship, can carry the twice
aircraft as any other foreign carrier, which
makes it even more shocking that it was sunk
by a single diesel powered swedish submarine
during war games in 2005.
A single submarine that cost the same as a
F-35 at 100 million dollars managed to sneak
by an entire carrier task force, with anti-submarine
defences to enter the red-zone and score multiple
torpedo hits on the USS Ronald Reagan, sinking
it virtually, before shrinking back into the
vast ocean undetected.
This was just one of many exercises where
the Swedish Gotland class submarine proved
too stealthy for the world’s strongest navy.
The new submarine proved so threatening that
the US military leased the Swedish sub for
an additional year to develop strategies to
counter the silent threat.
So what set the Gotland apart from other subs.
Submarines’ primary instrument to detect
enemy subs is sonar.
Sonar is essentially a finely tuned ear that
works like a whales or dolphins echolocation
to create a 3D map of ocean around it.
There is active sonar where the submarine
will send out a sound pulse called a “ping”
and listen for the reflections, but in warfare
this isn’t a sound strategy, as that ping
is detectable by enemies to give your exact
location, so passive sonar is used where no
ping is emitted and instead you simply listen.
These electronic ears are so accurate that
the nationality of submarines can be determined
based on the operating frequency of the alternating
current used in it’s power systems.
The 60 Hz alternating current of a US sub
could be differentiated from the 50 hz of
European subs, if the transformers and other
electronics were not adequately insulated
from the hull.
The Swedes managed to create a submarine so
silent that it was practically undetectable
by passive sonar, so how did they do this
at such a low cost?
The Gotland was the first submarine in the
world to use a stirling engine as it’s power
generator.
Stirling engines are not a new concept with
the first being created and patented by Robert
Stirling in 1816.
Inspired by a series of high pressure steam
boiler explosions at the beginning of the
industrial revolution, Stirling wanted to
create a safer engine that did not require
such high pressures.
I can’t be arsed trying to animate this
old drawing, let’s go for something simpler.
He did this by creating a closed cylinder
containing a fixed mass of gas permanently
sealed within.
Here one side of the piston cylinder has a
large buffer space, which allows for a relatively
constant pressure on this side of the piston,
while the other side fluctuates in pressure
due to alternating heating cycles.
When heat is applied to the outside of the
cylinder, the pressure increases causing the
piston to move until the pressure equalizes.
Now, if we cool the outside of the cylinder
with a heat exchanger, the pressure will drop
and once again the piston will move.
This is our basic pressure cycle to create
mechanical work.
But, this is an insanely inefficient system,
as most of the energy we put into the system
as heat is lost during the cooling cycle,
not to the gas, but to the actual cylinder
wall, which provides no mechanical work.
Robert Stirling solved this by adding a displacer
piston, which can drive the gas from one end
of the cylinder to the other.
Allowing this end to be permanently hot, and
the other permanently cold.
So the cylinder wall is no longer experiencing
a temperature cycle.
The pressure cycle here works slightly differently.
First the air in the hot end expands and causes
the displacer to move into contact with the
power piston, displacing more air from the
cold end to be heated and expanded, allowing
work to be done on the power piston.
The air on the hot end now has nowhere to
go, and so is driven to the cold end, where
it is cooled and contracts causing work to
be done once again on power piston.
This is our new pressure cycle.
The efficiency of this system can be increased
further by placing what is essentially a heat
battery in the tubes between the hot and cold
cylinder.
This conserves a huge amount of heat that
would otherwise be wasted during the cooling
cycle, and gives the heat back to the air
as it travels back to through.
Robert Stirling dubbed this the regenerator.
Now we have the foundations of a useful engine.
By incorporating a coolant system and a heating
chamber we create a larger temperature differential
to drive the engine, and the efficiency can
be future increased by increasing the number
of tubes connecting the hot and cold spaces,
along with the number of regenerators, and
adding fins to increase the surface area of
these tubes to allow for heat transfer.
Did I say simplified?
Sorry I meant easier to read.
Maybe I like the misery”
Stirling engines ultimately fell into obscurity
as stronger steel became available to make
steam engine boilers safer, but have seen
a resurgence in recent decades with the Gotland
being the most famous implementation.
The Gotland uses two Stirling engines that
use diesel and liquid oxygen to provide heat,
which in turn runs it’s 75kw generators.
These generators can run an electric motor
directly, or charge batteries that can provide
a huge boost in speed when needed.
All the while the exhaust is compressed and
stored on board, allowing the sub to stay
submerged for up to 2 weeks vastly longer
than any other diesel power submarine.
So why is it so silent compared to other submarines,
it doesn’t require much explanation as to
why using an internal combustion engine using
tiny controlled explosions for power tends
to cause some noise.
While the the multi-billion dollar nuclear
powered submarines need to pump huge volumes
of coolant to their reactors to prevent a
meltdown, causing enough noise to be detectable
by passive sonar within a certain range.
On top of this, recently declassified intelligence
suggest that Russian subs are using these
instruments to detect the faint trail of radiation
left in the wake of these nuclear powered
submarines.
Giving the swedish submarine another way of
avoiding detection.
This is a fascinating application of the laws
of thermodynamics.
Understanding and applying the laws of science
is the closest to a real life superpower in
this world.
So why not unlock your superpower of understanding
the universe by taking this course on Astronomy
on Brilliant.
This course take you from learning about the
tools astrophysicists use to observe the universe
through to the calculations that will allow
you to peer into the future of the universe.
Brilliant is a problem solving website that
teaches you how to think like an engineer.
You can dive in and start learning about a
huge range of topics starting from basic physics
and working your way up to more complicated
topics.
To support Real Engineering and learn more
about Brilliant, go to brilliant.org/RealEngineering
and sign up for free.
The first 73 people to sign up with this link
will get 20% off their annual premium subscription.
I get to learn and solve these kind of problems
for a living and I love it.
It gives me that warm glowy feeling inside
when I finally conquer a difficult problem.
Actively challenging your brain on a daily
basis and getting that endorphin rush of a
job well done is great for your mental health.
Brilliant even have an app where you can challenge
yourself on the go.
As always thank you to my Patrons and thank
you for watching.
If you would like to join the Real Engineering
community, I have recently set up subreddit
where we discuss everything engineering related
and more.
The link for that is in the description.